the Minnesota Vikings had an opportunity
to punch their ticket yesterday as the
sixth seed in the NFC and they failed
either a Vikings win or an eagle's loss
would have delivered a postseason for
the Vikings for the second straight year
it did not happen the Vikings lose to
the bears and the Bears went all out in
this one Chris they did not back off
even when it was obvious the Rams were
going to dismantle the 49ers the Bears
were not going to be in a position to
improve their playoff positioning they
still went for it they opted to knock
out the Vikings and I say all the time
you don't want a team from your division
by showing up in your Stadium in the
playoffs if you can avoid it however
this year was the asterisk this year was
the exception cuz I don't know that I
want the Eagles right and we could be
sitting here one week from now talking
about how the Bears should regret that
they let the Eagles in well you know
the Eagles are of course a hot football
team we get that the Bears you know
they're old school first of all they're
a young football team and they were
gonna continue to play and I think part
of it was because of what you said first
of all they're just going hey
Minnesota's on our way we have things to
improve on we're gonna take this as
serious as anything we've done all year
long and continue to improve our
football team and knock out a team that
we don't want to see for a third time
that has some elite defensive players
and two elite receivers that could in
one play change the dynamic of a game I
get it and I also I also think this hey
the Eagles are really good I'll say this
much though to me this is not a good
matchup for the Eagles I think it'll be
tough I do and they have some magic and
maybe I'm wrong here either way but I
think Chicago has some magic too just
with some of the weapons they have I
know you like some of the things I think
it bears at Soldier Field or a bad
matchup for n exactly agreed that's
exactly right so as much as the Eagles I
fear them I look at this still and go
watch out for the Bears I think would
the way everybody's played the last four
or five weeks if you made me rank the
NFC and I think you're on the similar
path here the Saints are the number one
team in the NFC but if you made me rank
them I'd say the Bears are the second
best team I think there's flaws with the
Rams Vikings were three and out on their
first four possessions similar what
happened last week in Detroit but in
Detroit they found the gas pedal yes
they never really found it against the
Bears 164 total yards and
cousins 20 of 33 132 yards one touchdown
no pics a 79 point for passer rating and
after the game Kirk Cousins addressed
the media and he was not able to pin
down precisely why the team struggled so
much much on offense in 2018 there you
can point to so many plays right through
16 games or you say if this one ball
bounces this way we're in the playoffs
even with today and so you can't get
caught up too much in today they all
count one and you can't get caught up
too much and you know we didn't deserve
this or that there's only so much you
can control as an individual player and
there's so many moments throughout a
season out of your control that happen
on the field that end up having a big
impact on the final outcome of each game
so you know at times you have to
understand that it's a lot bigger than
just any one person if you're watching
this on NBCSN and you're wondering why
the guys smiling you're not alone he's
smiling
he he's he's smiling like the the the
duck that they got when the bumpass
hounds ate the turkey yeah you know he's
smiling at me why are you smiling at me
Kirk why are you happy you shouldn't be
happy you should be upset you should be
sullen you should be more like Baker
Mayfield
I guess he's happy because he got 84
million fully guaranteed regardless
whether making the playoffs or not you
see that's why he's happy you sound like
a bit of riking Sam he's just being
pleasant he going home what is it what
the hell is pleasurable he's going he's
being pleasant he's not being a jerk to
the media he's trying to answer
questions professionally and be a
growing wait a minute wait a minute you
can be you can be not a jerk to the
media and also not have a goofy smile on
your face after your season just crashed
and burn at a time when you had high
expectations and you're the reason the
expectations were high I don't want to
see that goofy smile or your last press
conference and start giving everybody
the finger like you would I'm just
saying don't be smiling what are you
smiling about to smile about it's not a
smile like he's like this is the
greatest day of my life this is amazing
my first child's been born this is not
that kind of smile okay like hey you
know stop happens hey hey consequence
majek wants as long as I'm rich to your
point though he's allowed to smile
and then go home and be totally
distraught and angry and disappointed
about his season he doesn't look like a
guy who's gonna be distraught and angry
and disappointed be up all night because
it's in this hole oh it's one play here
one play there
baloney if you're a great team you don't
need to worry about one play here or one
play there those things happen and you
still overcome them that's what the
Patriots do we talked about that
yesterday there's no no I suppose talk
about Patriots Jetson yeah but bear with
us that that game was very close right
but those four or five plays yes they
always go when it's time to buckle down
when you know it's a key moment the
Patriots make it happen and they Bend
reality in their direction she's not
worried about oh this play here or that
play there no you go out and you out
execute the other team you are more
prepared you are more driven you are
more focused you are more talented you
are in better shape you are everything
necessary to advance that's what the
Bears are this year and that's what the
Vikings are yeah no the Vikings are not
that and I don't want everybody to sit
there and blame Kirk Cousins because I
don't think it's fair you know Spielman
that's your he gave them all that money
other other GM's did so so shame on you
for not realizing that I'm not worth the
money he gave me so joke's on you I
stink well shame on them for not having
a better offensive line this year shame
on them for you know going down the John
Dee philippa wormhole robbing those
issues so that didn't help it out either
that here's they should have kept Case
Keenum if they weren't gonna have a
great offensive line because you can't
make Kirk Cousins work as a quarterback
if he has to bail out of the pocket
Keenum was great he when he had the
bailout of pi is definitely more
Holliday was talking about this earlier
today yes he has to go to his right the
best thing you hope for is he throws it
out of bounds and lives to fight another
play he has to go to his left he gets
tackled and you just hope he doesn't
break his ankle on the way to the ground
that's it he's got no mobility
I just can't you're your Viking fandom I
love my buttons but I'm not real big on
the smiling I mean this isn't five hours
after I getting those the locker room he
takes a shower he puts on that shirt
that does not reflect the money that the
guy is making and he shows up and he's
smiling I I understand I don't want to
rip a guy for smiling well you are
we're smiling and he was just trying to
answer a question and not be a jerk you
know like you can still bill belly
that's what you say is a jerk so without
that vote the pad he's just trying to
give a pleasant answer to a guy why does
it matter to you that if he was like
this seek us all mad we lost scared what
how dare you ask that question media or
mad we lost but there's some I mean look
you're trying to get the fans because
the fans are pissed you have to play the
hands aren't smile uh-huh and they see
that and they say what they say when
you're stuck because you're a fan
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports